I was wondering if I smoke salmon. Is it all right for me to eat given my mesothelioma?
No, you should probably just send it to me and I'll consume it for you. Thanks.
Next question. No, I'm just kidding. Sorry. So, is smoke salmon bad for mesothelioma or any cancer?
I would say no. So, again, anything. So, you could find an article that smokes salmon causes cancer.
Barbecuing causes cancer. If you're right hand to brush your teeth causes cancer. Anything could
cause cancer done in excess, right? So, yeah, if you're going to eat all your eating to smoke salmon all
the time, then yeah, that probably would be good. But you want to use your barbecue to smoke some
salmon. By all means, I would say do that. I have a new grill. I wanted to try smoking my own salmon.
So, it would control the ingredients. Absolutely. So, I've smoked salmon before. Smoke a lot of things.
In fact, my mesothelioma just smoked a brisket. We're happy with that tonight. So, all for
using your much better off making your old stuff. So, I'd say you're fine.